being plus-sized in the social media
industry is definitely been hard there's
visibly fat plus-sized people and then
there's people with the quintessential
perfect curves like almost unfortunately
how plus- siiz are you okay so I um am a
plus-size supermodel so everything I do
is pretty much lifestyle around that
have a lot I'm put you first like just
you have so many streams of income
in spot
[Music]
haly spot
Grace first of all she makes enough
money would she make 120 Grand a year
pretty good money but but if that
depresses her or something then she
could just do something else seems like
she's setting herself up for failure
there